we get to carry down knowledge through
our bloodline through the generations 63
years of my family's work has led to
this moment of this person enjoying his
Grado and it's the best feeling in the
world
what makes grado Grado is the sound and
the story my family's been here since
1911 were still in the same building
since 1918 we were a fruit store now
we're an audio company the feedback we
get from people is there's a great owe
signature sound so we just might be
trained to keep that tradition going
my uncle he started out making
phonograph cartridges you'd make a few
one his kitchen table go out sell them
come back make a few more go out solemn
when the production exceeded the size of
his kitchen table he went around the
corner closed up great Oh fruit and
opened up greater laboratories and now
we're here it was said he had gold in
the ears he trained me how to listen and
what to listen for grown up here was
interesting I'd see them building
headphones and I would try but I would
just smash pieces together and I would
just play with them and think I was
building a headphone but I was probably
just breaking stuff Jonathan he is kind
of like our conduit to the world I also
just like a young face brought to the
company in the seventh or eighth grade I
had a career day to go to we had to
dress up as what we wanted to be when we
grew up then I came in dressed as my dad
which was jeans in a t-shirt and with
headphones on and I was like I'm gonna
be my dad and I'm going to do all this
stuff I mean it's just like when I kind
of took over from my uncle we've gone
through two generations and now the
third generation is being primed to to
take open
you